The next thing that we're going to take a look at are nulls.
Now nulls you can imagine work in a similar way to groups in Maya,
where they help you add essentially just an extra layer of control within your hierarchy.
We're going to add a null into the hierarchy of our control rig to give us control over
the head's rotation, whilst it's also aiming at the head control.
So we can sort of tilt the head if we want to while it's turning and
just add the extra level of control.
So the logical workers follows.
The new head control, which is this ring around our character's head at the moment,
will be a child of the null.
And the null is this sort of orange,
three-pointed shape that you can see inside the character's head.
And this control is basically going to follow that null wherever it goes.
And the null is going to be pointing towards our head aim control,
instead of what was the head bone previously.
And then this new head control, we'll use that to set the transforms of the head bone,
instead of the head aim control that's doing that at the moment.
So back inside the engine, we've opened up the head aim control rig,
and this is the one we're going to adjust and add a little bit of extra control to.
So the first thing we need to do is create our null.
And we want to create that at the location of the head,
because ultimately that's what we're going to be controlling.
So if you right click the head, come up to new and then new null,
that'll create a new null for us as a child of the head bone.
But we want to bring that out of the hierarchy and I'll press Shift P to do that.
And if I scroll down to the bottom, I actually want a hierarchy.
I actually want to re-parent that into the Spino 1 control,
so that wherever the Spino 1 goes, the head will follow.
Now you might find by default that you can't actually see your null within the viewport.
And if that's the case, you can come up to the option box up here and tick on display nulls.
Something else you notice is you can't actually move the null inside the viewport.
If you needed to move it, you could adjust the values here.
Or come up to the top to your solve direction and actually toggle on construction event.
Because that's what allows you to move the null within the viewport.
But since we're not going to need to move ours, I'm just going to right click it
and set initial transforms from closest bone,
just to make sure that we haven't made any adjustments to its initial position
when we've done the re-parenting.
Now we need to create our new head control.
And we want it to be a child of the null.
So I'm going to right click the null, come up to new and create new control.
And then I'll bring that up, drop it inside the head null.
And again, I'm going to set offset transforms from closest bone,
just to make sure that it matches the rotation of the head bone.
And I'll just adjust the look of it here so we can match sort of our spine and our root here.
And scale it up slightly.
And we can see we're off 90 degrees in the y-axis, so I'm just going to add 90 there.
And probably make it just a touch bigger.
Maybe make that three.
There we go, that's a little better.
And I'm going to rename that to be our head underscore control.
So if I right click rename, head underscore CTRL.
So in our hierarchy, we now have a new head null at the location of the head bone.
A child of that null is our head control, which means wherever that head null goes,
this head control is going to follow.
Now all we need to do is update our aim logic so that our head null is pointing towards the head aim control.
And then set the transforms of our head bone with the new head control that we just created.
So inside the head aim setup just here, we're going to change the item to a null and then input our head null.
And we'll see that as we move this, we can see our control low, which is a child of the null,
is actually now moving when we move the head aim control.
We come back and make sure display nulls is just turned on.
We can also see that the null is now pointing towards this head aim control.
Now all we need to do is tell the null to control the head control, sorry, to control the head bone.
And we'll do that with, well, a set transform and a get transform node.
And we'll do that by dragging the head in and choosing set bone and then dragging the head control in and choosing get control.
So we're going to set the bones transforms based on the head controls transforms,
which means that as we move this, the null is moving and pointing at the head aim control,
which is in turn moving the head control because it's a child of the null.
But then if we move this head control, we also get an extra layer of movement or an extra layer of control on top of the aim.
So that if you wanted to make sure something was looking at the aim control and then maybe cocking the head a little bit,
that's just a nice little extra level of control that you can have when you're using things like nulls.